Коляда на Гуцульщині своєрідна.
Такої коляди, можу сказати, нема ніде.
У колядників є такий, ну не занадто,
але строгенький відбір.
То страшно виснажує, змучує,
але то є така місія наша.
Ми як апостоли, ми йдемо,
сповіщаємо про народження Ісуса Христа.
Тебе благословили, тебе покропили свяченою водою
і ти мусиш ту місію свою виконати так,
аби не мучила совість.
♪  Ми коляднички, чесно вважаймо, ♪
♪ Наступну пісню Христу співаймо. ♪
♪ Стали в рядочки раду радити, ♪
♪ Треба нам, браття, коліднічити ♪
Ми вже більше 30-ти років беззмінно.
Мій тато покійний «березував»,
так само ходив колядував.
Колядує брат мій, теж «березує».
А ми разом чого? Ми це розгадали.
Ми бачили, що як десь щось, стається біда:
зсувається кусок землі або вигорає ліс —
першим деревом, яке там з'явиться, буде береза.
Береза — це дерево першопроходець.
Це дерево, яке веде за собою всі інші дерева.
Ви підходите до «берези» та й кажете:
«Ти, березо, березо, а в тебе є
такий загальний зошит з колядами?»
«Є».
Дехто каже: «А це ще зошит мого діда».
Ви піходите до другого «берези», а він теж має.
І зібрали ці зошити, надрукували тексти.
І зараз підготована книжка до друку
коляд Верховинського району
на основі зошитів оцих «берез».
♪ Господаречці вашого дому, ♪
♪ Ой з неба віха, до землі стріха ♪
♪ Дай вам Боже здоров'я, втіха ♪
♪ Та дай вам Боже з усього втіха ♪
За рядянщини то заборонено було.
Це десь збиралися верхами ходили
так, знаєте, в горах, не близько біля дороги.
Так нишком поколядую.
То було заборонено,
а потім вже коли стало потепління,
трошечки вже дозволили релігію відкрито,
що можна було й до церкви ходити.
Та й вже тоді почалися,
там один на селі був гурт, два.
Ви підходите до хати
та й під хатою ви плєшете [танцюєте].
І коли ви плєшите під хатою,
то ніби ви робите привітання для хати
і для тих людей, що живуть у тій хаті.
♪ В неділю рано сонце сіяє, ♪
♪ Ластівка в стрісі гніздо ввиває, ♪
♪ Гніздо ввивала  — защебетала, ♪
♪ Ґазді з ґаздиньом  — правду сказала. ♪
Ґазда виходить та й вирішує,
чи він запрошує цих людей в хату.
Бо запросити колядників в хату,
це значить чотири години,
стандартний набуток чотири години.
♪ Радуйся, ♪
♪ Ой радуйся, земле ♪
♪ Син Божий народився ♪
Але якщо вас в хату не приймають,
лиш гостять перед хатою,
то ви поплясали,
виходить ґазда та й дає повісьмо на хрест,
та й гроші, та й може вгостити,
та й ви пішли до другої хати.
Та й вибачайте, будьте здоровенькі.
Будьте здоровенькі.
♪ Ми славні ґазди, з горів Карпатів, ♪
♪ Ми прийшли до вас колядувати. ♪
♪ Пташки у вирій повідлітали, ♪
♪ Врожай із поля вже позбирали. ♪
♪ Христос родився, будем давати ♪
♪ Ісусу Христу славу віддати. ♪
♪ Ми, коляднички, чесно вважаймо. ♪
Традиційно жінки не йдуть. Чому?
Бо вдома діти маленькі, худоба, роботи багато,
а чоловіка легше відпустити,
тому що, колись чоловік пішов,
посвяткував, поколядував,
а жінка вдома «тягне возика».
Так було, такий був уклад життя.
Правда, зараз все по-іншому
і в нас були такі випадки, коли жінки йшли колядувати.
Вдома, потім з хати в церкву,
з церкви — церковне подвір'я,
на все село, і знову в хату.
Тож альфа і омега, початок і кінець,
де почали, туди й повертаємося.
У нас кожен присілок має свою колядницьку партію
чи колядницький гурт,
такого, на жаль, немає скрізь.
Насправді в кожному селі є вже ця коляда,
більшою- меншою мірою, але вже є.
Я думаю, що то все відновиться з часом.
Діти йдуть колядувати, це дуже файно.
Є вертепнички, найменші дітки.
Є пастушки, а є ще королі,
вони з коронами ходять, з бартками вже.
То зовсім три різних типи.
♪ Сидів Микола у чолі стола, ♪
♪ на стіл ся склонив, сльозеньку зронив ♪
— Як вам втрьох ходиться?
— Добре.
Супер.
Дякую, па-па.
Дімі вітання.
Ну звичайно, йдуть спочатку до рідних,
до сусідів, до хресних батьків,
один до одного, так само до родини.
♪ До ґаздині, ♪
♪ Щоби вони дочекали за рік цієї днини, ♪
♪ Щоби вони дочекали на рік цієї днини ♪
Кожна колядницька партія,
це її обов'язок прийти в кожну хату.
Навіть в хату, де ніхто не живе, поколядувати,
щоб там життя відновилося.
Вінчуєм вам нині, усі добрі люди,
нехай Божа поміч завжди з вами буде,
хай кожної днини, кожної години
Бог благословить, біда хай загине.
Будьте здорові разом з діточками,
нехай смуток і горе не будуть між вами.
Худібка і бджілка нехай виростають,
туча, горе нехай вас минає.
Нехай добре родить жито і пшениця,
усякії збіжжя, усяка пашниця.
Хай пісня не згине в рідному краї,
а наша Ураїна нехай процвітає.
Христос ся Рождає!
Коляди творяться до сьогодні.
Ми не просто співаємо колишні коляди,
як то було 100 років чи 1000 років тому.
Ні, ми співаємо так, як є сьогодні.
І все те надбання коляди, якому тисячі років,
яке природно є дохристиянським,
ми віддали Ісусові.
І, живучи в горах, живучи в цій красі,
яка є в нас, ми просто не могли бути іншими.
Можливо тому, що ми були
трошки ізольовані від світу.
А крім того, гуцули дуже пасіонарні,
і ми не можемо просто так сісти за стіл і поїсти.
Нам хочеться, щоб воно все було красиво.
Крім того, крім пасіонарності,
ми ще й свободолюбиві і не дуже
давалися чужим культурам, чужим владам.
І просто жили своїм життям.
♪ Та дай вам Боже мир в ці хороми, ♪
♪ Бо ми вже йдемо, будьте здорові ♪
Берегти свою культуру — це великий труд душі.
І от гуцули, як такі люди дуже творчі
і дуже такі витривалі, вони не поступилися цим.
Бо вони вважали, що як ми вже
в цьому відмовимо собі, то хто ми тоді.
♪ Ми коляднички, чесно вважаймо, ♪
♪ Барточки срібні вгору здіймаймо, ♪
♪ Барточки срібні в руках вбертаймо, ♪
♪ А ноги легкі — легко ступаймо. ♪
♪ Шоб веселися всі полонини, ♪
♪ Всі полонини, широкі поля. ♪
♪ Широкі поля, синії моря, ♪
♪ Бо колядочка — це Божі слова. ♪
♪ Як українська, рідная мова. ♪